Oh bla tu vas en pêchant ton
téléphone dans le drain je lui ai dit de ne pas le faire je
me coupe du monde
Footloose fantaisie libre ne sera pas seul
et l'île pour vous non je peux
avoir un verre de vin rouge s'il vous plait non je le
ferais  peupler l'île avec toutes les nouvelles
personnes que j'aime vraiment oui
mais ensuite les choses changent les gens que
vous pensiez aimer se sont avérés aussi
mauvais que les gens que vous avez laissés derrière bientôt
vous déménagez sur une autre île et ainsi de
suite et à l'infini
tu connais ma solution s'entendre
vraiment avec tout le monde alors pourquoi es-tu ici
seul dans un hôtel lié un samedi
soir Je ne te ferais certainement pas
attendre comme exactement parce que tu ne sais jamais à
quel genre de bel étranger je
pourrais commencer à parler
Je désire  nous devenons de meilleurs étrangers en
tirant la ligne de Shakespeare,
a-t-il dit, réussie pour vous normalement
j'ai eu mes moments avec elle vous savez que la
scène arrive excusez-moi monsieur oh merci
vous êtes si gentil
là vous revenez sur la grille
ce qui est  que les personnes les plus serviables sont
toujours là quand vous ne voulez pas d'
aide
ouais eh bien donnez-lui une minute va être de
retour avec un cordonnier hmm d'un autre
côté il est agréable d'être soigné de
temps en temps l'autre jour je me suis retrouvé
à ouvrir un  porte pour un homme qu'est-il
arrivé à la chevalerie
vous savez que mes gars ont ouvert des portes pour les femmes
non donc nous pouvons vérifier vos culs car vous
n'achèterez pas bien vous êtes juste plein de toutes
ces idées incroyables n'est-ce pas que je peux
dire en un  minute de rencontrer
quelqu'un si je veux être avec eux et
moi ils veulent faire avec moi oui
encore une minute d'accord
tu as une minute qu'est ce que tu vas en
faire Olivia qu'est ce que tu fais
ici j'étais en gobelin dans  au Festival du livre
et et qui m'a appelé et
m'a dit que tu viendrais qu'il
te rencontrait ici et que je devrais
venir te surprendre surpris si comme tahno
n'a-t-il pas oui alors comment as-tu fait le
lien je veux dire toi  're la célèbre
Olivia
ma belle soeur Olivia Olivia mon
gor  Géant anglais Richard merci beaucoup